each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
I'd like to introduce Joel Brandt is a
PhD student at Stanford he is graduating
it in a year hint hint and here to talk
about something I think is really
fascinating that he calls opportunistic
programming and take Thank You Gina so
good morning uh like Gina said my name
is Joel Brandt a PhD candidate Stanford
and I'm in the human-computer
interaction group there i'm also an
intern researcher in the Adobe Creative
Technologies lab so the sense I'm about
to say is probably the most important of
my talk none of this would have been
possible without all the help of my
wonderful collaborators at Stanford I've
worked with Phillip Kuo who actually was
an intern here this summer Joel Lewin
steen William Choi and my advisor Scott
clemmer and Adobe I've had the pleasure
of working with very closely with
meriden chava and also with Marcus West
camp as part of David's Allison's
research group and I really want to
thank Gina again for setting up
everything for my visit today it's so
far been awesome and I and I don't
expect that to change in the next few
hours so today's top will largely be
about how programmers use the web both
understanding how they're using it now
and understanding how we can build tools
that support that and so I'd like to
start out by presenting a vignette from
one of our exploratory studies so jenny
was working on building user interface
for a web based chat room so she was
staring at a blank Emacs window and she
said good grief I don't even remember
the syntax performs now Jenny's a great
programmer in fact she's a PhD candidate
and if she saw this syntax for HTML form
she'd know exactly how to use them she
doesn't need to learn anything she just
needs an external memory aid web search
makes finding this very straightforward
so your searches google for HTML forms
she clicks on the first result and she
quickly scrolls to code on the page a
quick copy and paste later and a few
typing changes and now she's already got
a mock-up of the user interface I'll
just took about 60 seconds something
that would have taken orders of
magnitude longer in the days before the
web in short we believe that the web has
fundamentally changed programming
practices it is now feasible for
programmers to build entire
applications by iteratively searching
for modifying combining these short box
of code and this enables what we call an
opportunistic approach to programming
where individuals interleave this web
foraging learning and writing code so
we've defined and actually folks at
Microsoft have also defined
opportunistic programming is the type of
programming that's done to prototype I
da and discover it emphasizes speed and
ease of development / code robustness
and maintainability now it's by no means
the only type of programming that gets
done but we believe a large portion of
the code written today is written this
manner it's certainly done by
professional software developers and
it's also done by amateurs by designers
mocking up user interfaces by scientists
writing code to run experiments and by
weekend hackers building the you know
the next generation of physical
computing devices so scafidi Shawn Myers
recently estimated that by 2012 which is
coming up there will be 13 million
people to do programming as part of
their job but only 3 million of these
people will be called full-time
programmers so we believe that for the
most part these other 10 million people
will be primarily engaged in this sort
of opportunistic programming and we
believe that there's significant value
in understanding and designing for this
large population of amateur programmers
sure you can ask them now sure the
definition could you just elaborate one
more time what is the definition of
professional
so I mean IIIi don't think that there's
a strict Academy here I mean I think you
know it's certainly a sliding scale i
think that there's people that would
self described as professional
programmers and those are the people
that work on development teams and you
know sit down in roughly 40 hours a week
write code and then there's lots and
lots of other people that just fall into
the practice of coding either you know
they start out using Excel or you know
like I said they're scientists and they
say I gotta hook this thing up to this
thing and so i'm going to write some
code you know these people that have
technical acumen that are willing to
jump into development but approach it
from a very different mindset they don't
need code that works all the time they
just need code that runs once and that
you know that's a perfectly valid reason
to write code because if you define am a
professional program or somebody who
doesn't know writing code for money you
know mm-hmm fun but it's basically 40
hours a week this is pretty much like
they're cool dunt job and then you
define unprofessional is just you know
people who do that every time that that
fair I don't think that's how I would
define it I wouldn't say it's something
that's done in their free time I mean I
think for lots of people this sort of
amateur programming is done as as as
part of in service of their job right
it's sort of I mean another way you
could draw this distinction another
domain is a you know how things work
with mathematicians right there's
there's professional mathematicians and
they do math all the time right in
whatever their area is there's also lots
of people to do math as part of their
job they do statistics maybe they do
statistics terribly I mean but whatever
they do they do those sorts of things as
part of their job and and we don't think
it's weird that math is just something
that everybody takes in college right
but you know we're just getting to this
point where computer science or or
programming is becoming that thing it's
a tool that people use even if that
isn't there you know soil profession is
that sort of clear things up so anyway
so this observation leads to the two
main researchers that all dress in my
talk today first how do programmers use
online resources and second how can we
build new programming interfaces that
support and more importantly amplify the
role of the web plays and software
development so the reminder might the
remainder of my talk will be divided
into two parts addressing each of these
questions in turn to answer the first
question is we can
directed to two exploratory studies one
in the lab and one in the wild our first
study observed 20 individuals in the lab
while they prototyped a web-based chat
room in this study we found that the web
played a principal role in all
participants development practices and
participants use the web with a varying
range of intentions to understand if
these results generalized we conducted a
second study where we analyzed a month
of queries to an online programming
search engine and we also saw traits in
this study that that suggested what was
being used for this the spectrum of
intentions and found that a queries
lexical structure the way we Ruiz were
refined and how people visited page were
very indicative of their different types
of intentions so in our laboratory study
like I said we observed 20 participants
prototyping a web chat room when
recruiting we ask that all participants
have a basic knowledge of PHP JavaScript
and HTML however all but two
participants rated themselves as novices
and at least one of these technologies
each session lasted two and half hours
and participants were compensated $99
participants were allowed to use any
resource while programming they were
told of ahead of time that they could
bring books or code to the session one
participant brought code on his laptop
no participants brought any printed
materials and all participants use the
web so we gave them a little bit of
information we said they would be
building a web application in PHP
javascript HTML we didn't say it's going
to be an ajax web chat room
yeah so he I mean he he'd you know he I
wouldn't say he selected code to bring
along he brought along his laptop which
had code on it he brought it along
because he knew that he could go and
look at it does that clarify things so
33 researchers one of them actually
who's Phillip and and three researchers
observed all the participants and one
researcher myself asked open-ended
questions as they programmed to get them
to think think aloud about particular
aspects of what they were doing
specifically relating to how they were
using the web when they were engaged in
programming the chat room then we asked
them to build we asked them to try meet
five specifications first the chat room
needed the user the chat room needed to
be able to set their username and
obviously post messages message updates
needed to happen without a page reload
so obviously they should use Ajax though
we didn't use that term when telling
them messages should also have a time
stamp and the chat history the length of
the chat window should be limited to ten
lines this last requirement was was
somewhat unique you know that's not how
most chat clients work but we added it
so that all participants would have to
write some code they couldn't just go
and get you know a PHP application that
that that does this chat and be done so
here's one participants chatroom that
met all the specifications and indeed
most most participants met all all the
specifications so this table lists one
subject burrow and shows that this best
shows what specifications they met and
an unfilled circle means that they
started on a specification but didn't
complete it as you can see 13 of the 20
participants met them all and most met
almost all of them and what we don't
have hard data on this because there's
really no way to test it we believe that
only one participant could have met all
of the specifications without being
allowed to use the web as a resource so
as I mentioned all the participants use
the web but how frequently do they use
it so the GAM China about to show spans
the length of the entire study and has
one line per subject and participants
web usage will be shown as white bars so
that's a ton of data and for the purpose
of this talk there's really only a few
things I'd like you to get out of this
chart first
use the web a lot and used it throughout
the entire course of the study on
average they use the web nineteen
percent of the time they were writing
code so about 25 minutes and they
averaged 18 distinct web use sessions
second the length of the sessions varied
greatly some lasted tens of minutes like
this one that's highlighted and some
lasted just a few seconds like the one
that's highlighted in the upper right so
what is the distribution of session
links look like suppose we sort all the
web sessions by length and then plot the
length of each session in order now if
all the web uses were for basically the
same purpose you might expect a roughly
uniform distribution instead we see a
power law like distribution this
suggests that the web may be playing
very different roles in these different
sessions indeed when we were looking at
the data exactly they were doing um I
mean we watched them work and so we
tracked him in a qualitative way well
that person did in 10 minutes versus the
person that did make it five seconds yes
stay tuned for the rest of the talk
that's that's what the next ten minutes
or so will be talking about so when
analyzing the data you know you need to
figure out some way of breaking down do
you have related three or four of your
disciplines didn't finish mm you
sterilize with well actually I'd love to
talk more about this we should maybe
take it offline I think the reasons they
didn't finish had less to do with their
particular web use strategies and more
to do with their overall programming
strategies so so interestingly the the
most I would say that it's hard to
generalize from three data points of
people that didn't finish right but the
thing that was the strongest predictor
of not finishing is if they chose to
start with a large body of code like you
know use something like a content
management system like drupal and build
on top of that so that's sort of
counterintuitive right you'd think if
they started with something that was
almost what they wanted that would be a
huge benefit in fact we saw them make
very very rapid initial progress right
so so one one of the participants that
didn't finish had met I think four of
the five specifications in 10 minutes
but that last specification the one that
we added where we asked them to limit
the
chat history he spent two and half hours
not meeting that specification so so you
know whereas whereas these other
participants that built things up from
small chunks to where they understood
each chunk and had an overall goal for
how to complete the task were much more
successful so yeah I'd love to talk more
about that anyway so when analyzing the
data we found that that understanding
program intention for each of these web
accesses was key to explaining how they
were using the web so this this
intention is clearly a spectrum but we
broke it into three separate categories
for the purposes of our analysis first
programmers engaged in just-in-time
learning of new skills and approaches
second they clarified and extended their
existing knowledge to sort of
implementation level details and third
they reminded themselves of details
deemed not worth remembering are not
worth typing so now I'll go through each
of these intentions and talk about some
key characteristics of each so that we
can talk about how they differ when
participants engaged in just-in-time
learning they often copied and modified
code before reading and tutorials pros
so this is really interesting one
participant said there's some stuff in
this code that I really don't know what
it's doing but I'll just try it and see
what happens so we believe that this is
because participants really require a
how the code works instructions which is
not how which is which is very different
than how to do a task instructions and
that's what tutorials typically provide
they say if you want to do this thing
follow these ten steps so instead
experimenting with and breaking the code
that they were provided you know I
structured this more guided reading of
tutorial where they could say I don't
understand this part I need to go and
read that portion of the tutorial the
next participants seem to be not very
concerned with deep learning one
participant said I think it's just less
expensive for me to just take the first
code I find and see how helpful it is at
a very high level as opposed to just
reading all these descriptions and texts
and finally participants often learn new
terminology from search snippet results
or search result snippets for example
one participant began with the all
English query PHP update page without
reloading and then saw the term ajax in
the result snippet before clicking on
any links he revised his query to PHP
tutorial so people are learning things
from the snippets and you know and and
taking little bits of knowledge that
they have and bringing them into making
their search experience better receive
that speed it was important like let me
get out of this user study as fast as I
can yep we made him stay for two and a
half hours but no no no you you have a
very good point what do you think how do
you think you can modify the design of
experiments you make them take the two
and a half hours and actually fix the
youths internet bars rather than trying
to speed through the day so that's
that's a really good question
experimental designs hard I think I
think there's a couple responses to your
question first off one of the
interesting things we saw in the study
was that what was an effect of this time
pressure so but but sort of an
interesting way so we'd for a lot of
participants we'd see them spend the
first let's say our doing whatever part
of the programming process they enjoyed
and and and going slowly through that so
maybe they were you know really a
designer and liked visual things they
would spend you know an hour getting the
HTML right for for their interface when
really that didn't matter for the
results of the study and then they would
you know start to feel this crunch and
try and get things done but I think that
actually feeling that time crunch is a
pretty realistic situation I think for a
lot of people especially people that are
just programming in service of getting
some other part of their job done they
want to get it done as quickly as
possible I think it's really hard to
design a study that doesn't have any
sort of time pressure and I'd be happy
to talk more about that if you have some
ideas so you're returning to these just
some time queries I'll summarize the
characters who saw in each of these and
we'll build this table up for for all
three of the intentions as we go so
first for learning queries a good
example query is something like Ajax
tutorial the terms in the query would
almost always be English they would
spend tens of minutes on the web and do
two to three refinements and click on
lots and lots of results five or more
they would typically visit tutorials or
how-to
and he would copy dozens of lines of
code will return to this table for each
of the the rest of the intentions so
let's move on to clarification first we
often saw participants use the web as as
a translator one participant received an
area that read xml filtering predicates
operator called on incompatible
functions so he mumbled what does that
mean and instead of trying to figure it
out because it was inscrutable he copied
the error message into his web web
search window wholesale and immediately
found a forum post that said this is
what you have followed exactly by the
line of Cody head and then this is what
you should have followed by a corrected
line of code so we just copy and pasted
that code and had no idea what the
actual bug was and things like this I
mean this is an extreme example but
things like this were very common
similarly similarly participants would
make language analogies to sort of adapt
their knowledge from one domain to
another domain so one participant said
perot as a function out has a function
that formats dates of strings so PHP
must as well and these uses participants
often could not write the required code
from scratch but in all cases they knew
exactly what the code did when they saw
which is very different than these
learning queries finally we observed
that participants trusted the code they
found in these uses and often didn't
immediately test it this caused
debugging problems when they made
mistakes in adapting the code so
interestingly the code was most of the
time correct but they introduced bugs by
copying pasting it and for example not
always changing variable names
consistently or things like that and
then they would assume that air is that
they experience wearing code they wrote
rather than the code they pasted again
let's let's review the characteristics
of these clarification uses so example
queries here tend to contain a mix of
code terms and in English terms and
sometimes they'll contain code terms
that aren't particularly relevant for
the language being used so JavaScript
doesn't have threads but you'll see a
query JavaScript thread that will lead
people to a forum post that tells them
to use set timeout instead which is a
threat like functionality so these these
term these the query terms usually mix
of code in English these accesses will
take about a minute they'll usually do
zero to one query refinements and 122
result clicks
these types of uses will take them to
API documentation blogs forums and
they'll copy several lines of code
finally participants use the web as an
external memory aid to remind themselves
about forgotten details in some cases
they explicitly chose not to learn
things after one participants searched
for an immediately copied code we asked
him if he'd ever copied it before he
said yes hundreds of times and then he
went on to say that he never bothered to
learn it because he knew it would always
be there in some cases web search
services web enabled autocomplete if
they would forget for example the
beginning portion of a method name
autocomplete wouldn't help them but web
web search would quickly recover it here
the participant forgot the exact name of
the my sequel fetch array function in
PHP he searched for PHP fetch array and
and the first result contained exactly
the information needed he didn't even
have to click on a result we did observe
that despite the utility of these uses
they often broke programmer flow because
the participant had to shift out of his
current programming environment and into
a web browser so finally let's let's
deal detail the characteristics of these
reminder uses yeah so we that's that's a
little complicated a point we provided
for everyone aptana which is a open
source ID for web development that
provides decent autocomplete especially
for PHP it's obviously not as good as
you could have for a statically typed
language uh but I mean in general that's
a that's a problem with with web
programming we also let participants
install their own ideas if they were
development environment if they wanted
to save choose this a job okay a c-sharp
and install a tu that had thought of
before
pretty good support for no sense do you
think that would change I think well
this actually is foreshadowing a later
part of our talk where i'll talk about
building tools for development
environments that bring web search into
the development vironment i think it
would change the results but not
dramatically because useful to use
autocomplete you need to have knowledge
about exactly what you want to do and
how determine still right so how do how
to phrase what you want to do which is
which you know the web plays a big role
in helping you do that sort of thing and
second even if you autocomplete to a
method name or you know a class name or
something like that that still doesn't
tell you how to use that thing for these
slightly higher level tasks you know
connecting to a database just finding in
you know in your auto complete the
method that connects to a database
doesn't tell you you know the three
steps you need to do to connect to a
database for that you need to either
jump down into some documentation or
find some example code or something like
that so I certainly think it would
change the results but I think not
dramatically so so let's let's go
through these things for reminder so
that we can contrast things so these an
example career here would be something
like fetch array PHP the terms are
almost always code and these accesses
generally take less than one minute they
usually require no query refinement
because people know exactly what they're
looking for and requires zero to one
result clicks they typically take people
to API Docs or just the result snippets
and you know sometimes people copy no
code from these accesses sometimes a
copy several it really varies so we
learn a great deal from this lab study
but we wanted a better understand if
these results generalized so we
conducted a large-scale query log
analysis we obtained one month of search
and result result click result click
logs from adobe's community help portal
which is a Google custom search engine
which indexes all kinds of adobe flex
specific content throughout the web as
you can see from this screenshot the
search results are presented in in a
manner very similar to popular
general-purpose search engines the
community helped data contained over a
hundred thousand queries from
approximately 25,000 programmers
all of the queries in this data set
we're about the adobe flex framework for
analysis we group these queries and
result clicks into 65,000 sessions where
a session was identified as a string of
queries from a single user with gaps no
longer than 6 minutes now this
methodology is pretty consistent with
with previous literature after this we
programmatically analyzed three
properties of each session first the
format of the query strings that is
whether they contain plating plain
English code specific terms are both
second the process of query refinement
and third the types of web pages visited
for example whether they went to
tutorials blogs or API documentation
finally we also hand coded 300 sessions
with respect to this intention I notion
of intention i introduced earlier
sessions were coders either being closer
to the learning or reminding into the
intention spectrum we didn't code for
the middle clarification intention sort
of due to insufficient context and again
I only have time to present a few
high-level results in this talk there's
a paper on this and so I refer you to
that if you'd like to see more details
on the quantitative analysis first we
found that query format predicted the
types of pages visited what do I mean by
that this table presents the types of
web page visit such as tutorials or
forms broken down by formatted queries
either code only English and code or
English each column here sums to one
hundred percent and so the numbers
present the percentage of for example
code only queries that go to a
particular page type so looking at each
row we see that Adobe API pages were
primarily visited as a result of code
only queries this suggests that API
pages are only helpful when participants
participants know exactly what they're
looking for next tutorials were most
commonly visited by english only queries
this again is not surprising
participants need tutorials when they
have a high level description of their
problem but don't know how to do it
finally blogs and forums were most often
arrived at through queries that contain
both English and code we speculate that
this is because such content is most
helpful in clarifying situations where
participants know only some of the
specific pieces involved in solving a
problem based on our hand coded data we
observe that sessions on the reminder
side of the attention spectrum were
typically code only queries so this
table presents a breakdown of
reformat by session intention again all
the columns sum to one hundred percent
we see that the code only queries
commonly Drive reminding uses an English
and code or English only queries drive
learning uses third we found that
programmers rarely need to refine
queries so this stacked histogram
presents a summary of the amount of
query refinement that happens during
search sessions in this graph the the
enth bar shows the total of number of
sessions that have an end query so the
first bar contains all the sessions the
second contains all sessions that have
at least two queries and so on each bar
is broken up by the format of that query
as you can see that the histogram tails
off rapidly there an average of 1.7
queries per session and this is
significantly smaller than for the
general population the lowest published
number we could find not a lot of people
publish date on this was about 2.2
queries per session so now if we if we
take this histogram and normalize the
height of each bar to 100% we can get a
view of how query content changes
queries are performed interestingly the
first queries are almost always either
code only or English only and as code
only queries are refined programmers
tend to add English the proportion of
english only queries however tends to
remain relatively constant so this
suggests that program win programmers
start off with english only queries they
may not know how to make them more
precise with code terms so now I'd like
to present five key insights that came
from these two studies that offer
simplifications for tool design first
this just-in-time learning is common in
programmers do this learning by
experimenting with the code this
suggests that we should maybe create
tutorials differently tutorials to teach
how code works and perhaps provide a
sandbox for users to experiment with
that code yeah
how the code works because what we
figured out is that people are much more
interested in learning how to show data
in a tabular way those two databinding
with a great view control because they
have no idea that there is a prickly
control and data binding they're
negative people if we specify the
tutorial in terms of how they would
phrase it we are much more successful
and it would only show how it gets done
but we wouldn't explain how the code
works it's just okay this is how you
will pass and so I don't know what all
the code was so be great it'd be great
to talk more about the studies you've
done because we haven't explicitly
looked at different types of you know
different ways to create tutorials and
how that actually plays out I'd love to
talk about that our intuition has if I'm
understanding you correctly our our
intuition is is not so much about how to
you know structure the the intuition or
purpose that that tutorial is provided
for I mean I think you're probably
exactly right about trying to get people
to the right tutorials but you know but
but about the necessary of providing
information about how a particular block
of code in that tutorial works so that
if people experience problems with it
they can fix those problems right so if
you know any code that they find in
tutorial if they just want to follow
that tutorial through step-by-step great
territorial be perfect for that but most
likely they want to do something
slightly different than the tutorial and
as soon as they have to change code they
you know tutorials don't teach them how
that code might be changed you know so
look so it shouldn't be that every
single line in the tutorial is is
explained you know there's lots of
boilerplate in there but the lines that
people are going to need to adopt to do
whatever their job is they need to
understand how those lines code are
working so hopefully that sort of dress
to your question and I'd love to chat
more about what you found second we saw
that copy code is often not immediately
tested so to aid debugging it would be
really helpful to demarcate which code
is copied code and then after the
execution of the program highlight code
that was and wasn't executed in fact we
saw people waste a tremendous
amount of time thinking that code Randa
didn't even run or vice versa third we
saw that search was often used as a
translator so I'm certainly not an
information retrieval expert but perhaps
we can automatically extract these
synonyms for for code specific searches
and use this to improve ranking
additionally perhaps we can
automatically search the web for the
content of error messages so that we can
help people find bugs sooner fourth we
saw that programmers often choose not to
learn syntax so this suggests that we
should put search inside the development
environment and make you know current
autocomplete to those sort of web
enabled and finally we saw that purchase
that when participants refine queries
their query refinement was often
predictable for example they would often
add versions of libraries or frameworks
to improve the result set so this
additional context is is available in
the development environment and perhaps
we could use this context that's present
environment to automatically augment
queries so the programmers could find
good results faster so I'd like to take
these design guidelines as a driver for
the second part of my talk investigating
how we can build tools that support and
amplify the use of the web during
programming given the great diversity of
web views that I've just described we
believe there's significant value in
building very task specific search
interfaces for each of these intentions
so returning to this graph from earlier
our recent work that I'm about to
describe focuses on this long tail of
task in this clarifying and reminding
end of the spectrum improving the gist
and time learning aspects of web use
remains exciting future work for us and
I'd be happy to talk more about the
things that you guys are doing in that
space as well the main insight behind
the tool I'm about to describe is that
milliseconds matter specifically we
believe that lowering the threshold to
complete what are already brief but very
common web search tests we do more than
just get a programmer home from work 90
seconds earlier instead we believe it we
hoped and believed it would cause a
fundamental change in the way that web
search was used during programming so we
began with the observation that tools
programmers use to search and consume
the web are wholly separate from those
that they used to write code
the web browser and search engine have
no access to the incredible amounts of
context in the users code despite the
fact that the code is intended to be
read by computers similarly the ID has
no notion of code provenance instead of
soon as that every character that enters
the editor has been type a hand what
benefits might be realized by removing
the spanner barrier to explore the
question we built blueprint blueprints a
plug-in for the adobe flex builder
development environment that integrates
web search and code authoring
experiences so I'd like to show you
begin by showing you scenarios blueprint
in use in a scenario will follow a
programmer as she uses blueprint to
build a web application that allows
people to graph and compare their power
consumption so this programmer begins by
creating a project and adding some
boilerplate code the first thing that
the programmer wants to do is load some
data from the web so they start by
creating a load data function and then
they say I've done this before I have
some knowledge about how to do it and I
know that there's a class involved that
that begins with URL so they'll bring up
autocomplete Oh video controlling video
control and power point is not a deal
perhaps that's only a mac only problem I
meant to pause playback so create some
boilerplate code and then starts out by
using auto complete so says you know I
know that I've done this before I know
one of the classes involved has a name
that begins with URL so they'll open up
their auto complete and say oh yeah URL
loader that's it that's the class that
I'm interested in using but this is as
far as autocomplete will often get you a
lot of times you'll say okay well great
I want to use a little you are elder but
I have no idea how to use it and this is
when programmers will typically drop
down into you know Firefox and a search
engine and try and find example code
blue fern allows you just hit another
hot key and go and perform that search
on the web without leaving your
development environment now the result
view that we present in our search
engine is very example code centric so
that's the thing that's for grounded so
as you scroll through it here you see
code that uses the URL loader object and
if you've done this before parsing this
code is is fairly straightforward you
look through it and you see several
different examples that are doing
different things
one has lots of air handling which might
be nice another one further down here
automatically loads the resulting URL
into an XML object and parses it so in
this example the programmer finds that
and says this is exactly the code I want
so they go and just select that code and
they hit enter to bring it into their
development environment we provide
information about where the code came
from so if they ever need to get back to
the web page they can do that also how
they access the code so the programmer
runs that code after replacing the URL
and confirms in a debugger that she's
actually getting the the XML she
expected so now the programmer so this
is another common way that people enter
the blueprint user interface they'll say
there's something I want to do that I
know is one line of code like setting a
busy cursor right but if you don't know
the class involved in doing that you
simply can't use autocomplete to start
that process so with our search
interface you can search with plain
English just type something like busy
cursor and perform that search and
immediately you see oh there's this line
of code right here cursor manager if you
didn't know what's called cursor manager
dot set busy cursor so it's a very
simple call one line of code and this
allows you to get to that very rapidly
so the user here copies these two lines
of code for setting the busy cursor and
removing the busy cursor and so will see
that occur here
so now when when she compiles her coach
he sees that she's missing an import
statement from busy cursor so sure she
could write this but she can also very
quickly return to the web and get that
import statement you could also imagine
doing some semantic code analysis type
stuff to try and help people get the
right information this third case shows
another way to use blueprint so you can
also dr. blue print within your
development environment here the user is
search for charting and is looking
through different charts to get an idea
of how she might want to visualize the
data that came back now the nice thing
we're able to do is in some situations
we can pull out running examples as well
as source code and present those running
examples alongside the source code so
that people can see what the code does
so here the user selects uh some some
code for a line chart adapt it real
quickly to bind it to the data and in a
matter of minutes there's a mocked-up
user interface and you'll see that in
just a second
so let's real quickly take a look at the
interface first users can initiate
queries a number of ways they get a
hotkey on a line of code that has a
short amount of text and that entire
line of text is used as the query or
they can select some text in their
editor and hit a hot key to use that as
the query term or they can simply type
into the query box and in search in a
traditional manner in all cases we
provide additional query suggestions to
the user each query result has a title
which is taken from a source web page
anything is just in an english
description that we automatically
extract and also a link to the source
web page if they want to go and see the
example in context the most prominent
feature is the example code query terms
are highlighted within this source
content everything that you know yes is
coming from the documentation for the
Flex is that coming from blogs it's
coming from essentially the web as a
whole I'll talk about that next about
how how we service queries but to give
you a really brief answer this is
sitting on top of that exact same Google
custom search engine that I was talking
about earlier in the talked the index is
Adobe flex content from all over the web
so I'll talk about that in just a second
how our particular extraction and query
servicing works so in the in the code
result view we highlight all of the
query terms which as I'll mention later
proved to be vitally important for
people using the interface finally when
we're able to we sometimes are able to
extract a running example of the code so
that users can interact with it and see
what the code does so now getting to
your question I'll give you a brief
overview of how blueprint works Weaver
blueprint consists of three main parts
the client plug-in which provides the
interface you saw our blueprint server
and then an underlying search engine
here this Google custom search engine
that I talked about when a user creates
a query like chart what you just saw the
blueprint client takes that and augments
the query with contextual information
things like the language they're using
particular versions of frameworks are
using and sends all this contextual
information
to the blueprint server the blueprint
server then uses some rules to take
those contextual information and turn it
into what we consider a better Google
query we send this query off to our
Google custom search engine and it
obviously returns a list of URLs and
also a list of autocomplete suggestions
the blueprint server then parses this
list of URLs goes and looks at all of
the pages and tries to extract example
code and English descriptions from those
pages this is actually this actually
occurs offline in his cash so that we
can do this in in a real-time manner the
boot print server then sends all of this
data along with some additional data
things like documentation pages that we
know are relevant and the query
suggestions we got from google back to
the interface which renders the examples
so I'd be happy to talk more about how
we extract example code from these web
pages and things like that that's a
little bit nuanced so probably not
appropriate for for the scope of this
talk but I'd be very happy to talk about
that stuff oh it doesn't what it what it
says an Englishman so actually it turns
out the answer that question is mostly
legal issues so we only it turns out we
only extract running examples so running
Swift files in this case because it's
it's flash from adobe web pages we don't
extract them from from third-party web
pages and there's lots of good reasons
for that a lots of good security reasons
and things like that so you know for for
those adobe web pages we have you know
reasonable confidence that are you know
the people working in Adobe are trying
to create the right you know right
running examples does that answer your
question I mean yeah so it's a really
good point I mean yeah there's there's
all these really interesting security
issues around serving up other people's
content and also lots of legal issues
about serving it up so we have an opt-in
program that allows people to specify
whether they want all of their code
included in the search engine or just
some of it and I don't want to go into
that in this talk because it's just
legal stuff it has nothing to do with
the research but I'd be happy to talk
about it later
this code was useful um so we do I don't
know if you let me see if I can go back
to that really easily I didn't mention
this in the interface we in fact we do
have opportunities for people to rate
examples explicitly no one does this
literally no one right like we have
thousands and thousands of queries and
thousands and thousands of copy and
paste events and six people have rated
grades so there's also I think a lot of
opportunities for sort of implicit
feedback there are on yep so like did
you leave this code around in your did
you leave the patient code around in
your code I mean I think it would be
huge to be able to use that information
unfortunately there are also lots of
legal issues with that so that's that's
been a really interesting trade-off and
doing this research obviously I'm a
Stanford grad student but we've been
doing it in conjunction with Adobe
because there's so many benefits we can
get with working with a real corporation
right I mean we can get it out to
literally thousands of users we can
build you know on top of existing data
sets we can get access to logs that we
would never get an academia which is
awesome but it also means that we have
substantially more legal constraints
than we would if we were just a bunch of
university students causing trouble so
again I'd be happy to talk about that i
wish i could give better answers but you
know uh so going on so the next thing i
want to talk about is how we've
evaluated blueprint and i personally
think this is the most exciting part of
this work so to better understand how
blueprint changes a search experience we
conducted again two studies the first
was a comparative lab study with 20
participants and the second was a three
month deployment we had over eight
thousand people install blueprint and a
little over 2,000 does actually used it
for real which i think is a pretty
pretty normal drop off those two
thousand users constructed over 17,000
queries in the three months man so as
with the studies i discussed earlier i
don't have time to detail all the
results so instead i'll present the most
salient findings from each of them our
first study was conducted with 20
participants all of those participants
were Adobe employees to use flex as part
of their job participants were randomly
assigned to one of two conditions they
would either use blueprint or Adobe's
community help search engine what you
saw before
in a regular web browser to find
resources well completing programming
test and that was the only resource they
could use all participants followed a
tutorial task that was basically
identical across conditions that taught
them how to use the search interface
they were assigned all participants were
then asked to complete two tasks the
first was very directed they were asked
to just like you saw in the demo load
data from URL and were asked to write
this code as quickly as possible the
second was exploratory they were asked
to visualize the data set that was
already in their code and produced what
they believed was the best visualization
of that data we limited each task to ten
minutes and for both tasks we measured
the time to the first code paste the
time to task completion and we had
independent experts outside of our study
rate the quality of code produced and
the visualizations produced so in our
directed test we found that participants
selected and copy code significantly
faster with blueprint than with
community help so this graph shows the
rank order of participants time to first
paste and the solid squares are users of
blueprint blueprint users average 50
seconds of 57 seconds from starting the
task to their first code paste whereas
community help users averaged just over
two minutes task completion time was
very strongly correlated with time to
first pace so this sort of suggests that
blueprint helps people write code faster
additionally and perhaps most
interestingly participants who use
blueprint wrote significantly better
code as rated by an outside expert so
code that had appropriate error handling
and things like this and we think this
is because blueprint users could very
quickly scan lots and lots of example
code so they were able to select a
better starting example good
well I mean you know when people are
asked to hurry not everybody chooses the
best example right i mean the code was
code was pretty similar across users and
so I mean there's probably ten good
examples of how to do this URL loading
task on the web and so if you get two
people that choose the same one their
code is likely to turn out about the
same in the end so i wouldn't i wouldn't
i think the the high level picture is a
lot more important here than the
particular data points but that's a
great point so the results from the
exploratory test where a task were a
little less dramatic as expected all
participants used all 10 minutes so
there's there's no time data there as
they were trying to produce the best
design they could when those designs are
rated by an outside expert we found no
statistically significant difference in
quality so it's certainly good that
blueprint didn't make participants
perform worse but we would have liked to
see them perform better and I think the
biggest reasons behind why they didn't
perform better were user interface bugs
so it's not particularly easy in
blueprint right now to compare multiple
examples at the same time you can't see
all of the different types of charts
that you could create for example and
you know you can't do that very well on
the web either but we certainly don't
make that task easier you know I think
you can imagine interfaces that would
make this sort of comparison a lot
easier so again we wanted to understand
you know we had an idea that we were on
the right track with blueprint but we to
understand if we're really changing how
people use the web through this task
specific search interface we needed to
put blue print out there and see what
people really did after they'd had it
for a while so we conducted a three
month deployment in fact it's still out
there you can download and use it and
examine user behavior through log
analysis and interviews blueprint was
deployed on the adobe labs website 2024
users performed 17 thousand twelve
queries over these 84 days we logged
queries and user interface actions so
things like copy and paste at the end of
the study we conducted structured
interviews with for users recruited
through a special prompt in the
interface so one problem with just doing
log analysis is that with enough data
you can sort of tell any story you want
to write so the principal person these
interviews wasn't to gather v
a quantitative hard data but instead to
drive the creation of meaningful
hypotheses that were really worth
testing in this data rather than just
finding something because there's lots
of data we can player we compared
blueprint logs to the logs again from
this immunity Adobe community help
search engine and I want to remind you
that the blueprint users that blueprint
is is this exact same underlying search
engine and the user populations using
these two search interfaces are the same
so really the only thing that differed
in these two log sets was the search
interface used like what percentage of
overall Adobe technology users are
so it's actually a very surprisingly
large number and one of the reasons for
that is if you search from within the
application so just through the regular
help interface it takes you to this this
community help search engine and so
that's how most people are arriving
there I think the interface to get to
that search engine just by browsing the
web is incredibly cumbersome so I think
it's very unlikely in it people are
arriving there by chance or by just
general web browsing I think everybody
is either arriving at this through you
know the help system in their in their
development vironment or something they
bookmarked or something like that after
once arriving at it or obviously people
using blueprint grabbed a blueprint
three labs into the promotion we did is
that yeah yeah that's true so we should
we could talk more about this offline uh
professional flash developers is kind of
a funny term because interestingly most
people who write flash professionally
have no computer science training so
it's a really interesting population but
anyway we could I would love to chat
more about that so anyway now now I'll
present are the results from our log
analysis and for each of these all offer
this high-level insight that came from
our interviews and state the hypothesis
that we generate from that and then
finding I'll describe what we found when
testing that hypothesis so first all
participants indicated that the benefits
of having this consistent result view
substantially outweighed the drawbacks
of removing examples from their original
context so specifically we asked a one
person when we asked all the interviews
but when we asked one of them about
whether additional context was ever
necessary he said highlighting it was a
search coat search term in the code is
Cle key I scroll through the results
quickly and I can find code that has it
and I can understand the code much
faster than I could English so this
indicates that some help is required but
but really when you're engaged in the
active coding there's this very small
Gulf of evaluation to understanding of
code is something you want and a lot of
the context gets in the way in these
cases so broadly speaking if additional
context is rarely necessary we'd expect
that blueprint searches would have
significantly lower click through
then community helps searches so so in
the blueprint interface you can click
through and get that context if you want
to it appears in the same window and
it's very easy to get that context
indeed blueprint users clicked
substantially less with an average of
point three eight clicks per session
versus 1.32 for community help so that's
a huge difference in amount of click
through second many interviewees mention
that they use blueprint and conduct in
conjunction with other ID features for
example as you saw in the video they
would use autocomplete define classes or
properties of interest for some task
that they wanted to complete and then
they would use code generated by the
code generated by autocomplete to
initiate a search and blueprint so in
short blueprints seem to be working sort
of symbiotically with existing ID
features each kind of making the other
more useful so how would this manifest
itself in the logs well one way to look
at this behavior is to look for
occurrences of what you might call
correctly formatted code so code is
produced by ID features like
autocomplete will be correctly formatted
having all the necessary you know
capitalization and things like that that
people might not bother to carry over to
a search engine when they're typing by
hand so if such code is indeed more
frequently occurring in blueprint than
it does in community help this would
suggest that blueprint is really being
used in this manner now we have this
nice property that because the flex
framework uses this coding convention
where everything is in camel case it's
very easy to look for cases where camel
case is used so indeed camelcase words
appear substantially more frequently in
blueprint queries than in community help
queries almost half of the queries
contain contain camelcase words in
blueprint whereas only sixteen percent
of them do in community help searches
finally our participants indicated that
they use blueprint very heavily for
these clarifying and reminding tasks one
per different said I thought I can find
what I need sixty-eight percent of the
time without having to go to api docs
another participant mentioned that he
would often use blueprint to make sure
he wasn't forgetting anything in a task
he did routinely so it wasn't about
copying code instead he would for
example routinely pull up a block of
example code to make sure he hadn't left
out a step when his example was when
setting up transformation matrices for
the flash stage right so there's three
or four steps you have to do in that
process
and just bringing up example code you
can compare to his code and say oh yeah
i forgot that step or this is the right
thing he went on to say that blueprint
works well for that mid space between
when you don't know what you're doing at
all and when you need help and and and
when you don't need any help at all
because you know exactly what you're
doing so following these intuitions we
believe that re finding content would be
substantially more frequent with
blueprint than with community help
because it's being used for these
reminding clarifying and repeat tasks
indeed this hypothesis we found this
hypothesis feature as well 12.2 percent
of the sessions from high frequency
users of blueprint again we only looked
at people that had used it as a
substantial amount of time as with
community help contain queries that were
identical to a query from a prior
session compared to only seven point
eight percent of queries from from
community help finally we took a look at
the top 50 queries from both interfaces
so as you might expect the most common
series the most common searches are
quite similar 10 of the top 20 terms for
each list appeared in the other lists
you know these are things for these are
searches for things like button or
canvas so this isn't particularly
interesting what is interesting is that
the relative frequencies of terms were
sometimes quite different in these in
these two search interfaces and perhaps
the most dramatic case is that of the
query for alert so queries for alert
which is the call necessary to display a
simple pop-up dialog very similar to
JavaScript we're substantially more
common in blueprint this was ranked
eighth and blueprint and 34th and
community help and the frequency of
things between eighth and 34th the
frequency change is huge so why might
this be all right well First Alert
statements in flex our are slightly more
complicated than you might be familiar
with in JavaScript they have three
parameters all of which have to be set
so you have to do a number of things
it's a little more complicated second
alerts are most commonly used during
debugging right and I'm sure many of you
are programmers are familiar with that
they're convenient for you know
conveying information to the programmer
and allowing the programmers stay in the
interface so in some in some situations
they're much preferable to print lines
or trace statements things like that but
there are of course simpler alternatives
it's much easier to use a trace
statement or a print line
so let's look at the result interfaces
for this query as you can see blueprint
immediately displays the one line of
code necessary to display an alert
dialog right here someone using
community help would have to click on
the first result and wait for a while
for the page to rule wrote page to load
then scroll through several screens of
content to find this exact same line of
code because the first result is an API
page that doesn't have code until no
bottom so we believe this is an example
of how test specific searches search
interfaces can change the space of tasks
for which search is a viable tool
without blueprint users may may instead
be choosing you know to take suboptimal
approaches like using tray statements
because the cost of searching isn't
worth the benefit so you can call it in
conclusion we believe that these results
show that task specific search
interfaces can cause a fundamental
change in how and when individuals
search the web moreover we believe that
programmers increasing reliance on the
web is changing the nature of what it
means to be a programmer in fact in the
future we suggest that it that
programming may become less about
knowing how to do a task and more about
knowing how to find the right answer so
thank you so much for your time today
I'd be happy to take any more questions
it's very important that they get to the
solution quickly less expensively do you
actually think that's
different to one of the opposite ease of
opportunistic professional programmers
well I think there's there's two things
to say to that first off I first time I
think there are differences but but I
think more importantly professional
programmers certainly engaged in this
opportunistic activity when they're
prototyping new things and stuff like
that I think that there's that that part
of being a professional programmer means
that you're often in situations where
you need to make sure that you do
something right that something's done
systematically something's done you know
with a minimum number of bugs in a way
that's you know verifiable and a sort of
thing so I think in those situations I
mean you always want to you know get
your job get your job done and go home
and sit in front of the TV but I think
the trade-offs between doing something
quickly and doing something right change
for professional programs a lot more
than they do for these amateur
opportunity programs same research
specifically about it
not that I'm aware of so Stephen Clarke
and Monty hammontree who are both on the
visual studio team here at Microsoft
where as far as I know the first people
that sort of coin this idea of
opportunism and programming and there's
there's I think this is one of these
things where there's lots and lots of
anecdotal evidence for it but there's no
you know you can't I don't know if
numbers you can point to that say you
know this percent of the time they're
thinking about this and this percent of
time this other populations thinking
about this I I think it'd be fascinating
to get that data may be entering you
talk about how to get it titled
approaching so worried if you are
working if you're designing a class
library doesn't framework you have to
make sure that it scales nothing is nice
good but if you have your project you
will develop our customer and Marcus
customers 10-15 people working with us
software solution you don't care about
the the architecture there's no need for
interior architecture
your database application yes can do
millions millions of transactions per
second and i think it just slap it
together and steer it around them I
think it's nice to think that but rather
than I think it's more to do with people
and I think the probability that there's
more opportunistic programming going on
that we'd like to think is it's pretty
high I think most people care about
going to solution and yes they know they
should be caring about beautiful elegant
code but well and I mean I mean it mean
to carry your ideas to the extreme I
think you're absolutely right um you
know I mean I i I'm a fairly proficient
programmer and i right tons of code in
this very very opportunistic manner code
that I would never want the world to see
because it's code that's going to run
exactly one time you know it's you know
I I don't care if you know I don't care
if my algorithm to sort this you know
stuff that I'm extracting from this log
file runs particularly quickly because
i'm going to process this log file once
right and that's a very different type
of software development and a very valid
form of softer element compared to you
know our traditional models and yet
we're using exactly the same tools do
those sorts of things look at this most
space of your opportunities so developer
I mean they're usually the customers
they serve they have a budget of 500
Donna's thousand bucks 1500 so they
can't afford to spend 10 days 15 days
toward to get everything right like the
more projects they can do they pay more
money they have in their pocket there is
no there's no time for lunch at the
center
if given the choice between taking a
long time to do it's asking a little bit
of time to do a task i'm always going to
choose a little bit of time to go to us
i would say so if your if your customer
if like okay if i would go to to my
climbing trip where they have an
application where they scan my badge and
all the doors but when I common I mean
how much would the climbing should be
willing to pay for this application five
hundred dollars anymore just switched
into their professional programming
realm like if somebody's paying you for
this kind of job like I think we're
talking about different careers now and
and i would i would suggest that like
there's this whole end user software
engineering consortium of people who
study the end user and basically like
people more programming of PHP website
for their church where people were like
doing a spreadsheet or a budget for
their for their boss and they have lots
of calculations in their presence
protein they don't necessarily even know
what code elegance means they don't have
any idea what testing is or that they
should be doing it or what maintenance
is we're coding for maintainability they
have very different their goals are
basically i need to get this job done
because somebody told me to do it this
is currently thing i have to do in order
to get it done I'll do anything
let's get it done and then i'm done and
i never have to think about it again my
point is we'd like to think that people
working on windows or Visual Studio
alphas doesn't do put dissolution
opportunistic programming and I think
they do don't even if they do it just as
a you know past zero and then they can
pick and choose from it and say okay now
I've got to add the security hardening
or whatever it is I think the they'll
obviously still be using the reminder
mode mm-hmm did you know the API service
is just too large to have everything yep
yep I mean I mean how long we have we
seen application that you call the time
you presented to a customer and us
develop that the intent that okay this
is the prototype this should never ever
be productive no let's make it real or
the customers at that that's good enough
at work yep well yeah I mean and in
fredburg says great commentary about
this thing I mean this sort of thing I
mean the problem is that it's actually
too easy to reuse code right that
there's lots of code that was written
that you know if you'd built if you were
doing if you're a mechanical engineering
you'd built a physical model you would
have thrown it away like that's what
would happen and it doesn't happen in
software development
that's a great question um i think well
i mean i think i think uh i think it
would be great to be able to sort of
segment the population that we're
looking at in two different smaller
segments and understand how different
people were doing things differently so
if we could look at all of the people it
you know if you could for example
compare you know all the people that had
a computer science background and all
the people that had a design background
and see how they differed I think that
would be fascinating I think you'd need
a slightly larger population to be able
to do that but you'd also need more
contextual information which we don't
have so I think that would be
interesting to do I also think our most
interesting next research steps are sort
of parallel to the things we've done
rather than in greater depth of it and
in what we're doing now I think there's
a lot of really interesting questions
about how you change the the editing and
code execution and debugging environment
you know with the intuition that lots of
code that comes into your editor you
didn't write right nobody's really
thinking about how the editing process
should change for this new type of
development so is he taking office fish
more languages and you're going to get
all this yep yep you said this legal and
moral issues yep well I think I mean I
think also we talked about this a little
bit I think that if we could get more
data on how people are using the code I
think there's tons of really interesting
things that you could do with that
especially if you had a great background
information retrieval so I think there's
a lot you can learn about what code
examples were good to improve ranking I
also think there's really neat things
you could do where if you can watch how
let's say 10 people use this example
what things they change then for the
11th person you could say okay well
you're probably going to want to change
these three literals out of this
boilerplate you need these six lines in
this one line but you don't need all
this stuff and don't forget this line
everybody copied that right I mean I
think so as we start to get lots of data
you could you could do those sorts of
things I think I think all that work be
absolutely fascinating also control the
content piece of it have input into
everything that's great input to tune
yep yeah and it's also a great I guess I
I don't know if you were saying great
input to tune in the interface or great
into in to tune the actual content okay
yeah okay then we're saying exactly the
same thing yeah I totally agree great
any other questions I'd also of course
be happy to chat about anything else
offline so thank you so much for
inviting me